cada semana este grupo de niños visita
la playa de muy sinverg los jóvenes
autistas disfrutan la oportunidad de
salir de los lugares donde viven
quiero que escuchen los sonidos que los
rodean
cualquier sonido la playa los pájaros y
un breve respiro adentro y afuera
los niños hacen ruidos de animales las
sesiones de calentamiento duran
aproximadamente una hora antes de que
ellos puedan golpear las olas la
excursión no se trata solo de mejorar
las habilidades de surf sino también de
exponer a los niños a situaciones
impredecibles y así ayudarlos a
funcionar en la sociedad de manera más
independiente
en el programa ayuda a los niños a
funcionar en situaciones en las que
normalmente estarían bastante nerviosos
ansiosos o asustados los niños autistas
tienen desafíos sensoriales son muy
sensibles cosas como escuchar el océano
sentir el agua cuando está muy fría la
arena bajo sus pies
la atención clínica para el autismo es
escasa en áfrica y sudáfrica alrededor
de 1700 niños se han beneficiado de este
programa gratuito
y nuestra pasión es la salud mental
queremos ayudar a seguir adelante con la
conversación sobre salud mental
desestimar la salud mental y también
asegurarnos de que las personas reciban
un servicio de calidad creo que todos
podemos irnos a casa y darnos una
palmadita en la espalda
el enfoque de la ong es mejorar las
vidas de los menores ayudándolos a
navegar su discapacidad con tanta
valentía como lo hacen con las olas